hi there steve kaufman here and today
the olympics are on in rio i'm going to
talk about learning portuguese remember
if you like my channel please subscribe
and if you have any questions or things
you would like me to talk about please
let me know
um i thought i would talk a bit about
portuguese because we're some of us many
of us are watching the
olympics in brazil and despite all of
the you know bad reports that we always
get in the lead-up to any olympic games
whether it be vancouver which some
british newspaper called the worst
olympics in the world ever and then all
the problems about toilets and sochi and
pollution in rio and stuff but it looks
like actually things are going on are
proceeding
swimmingly so to speak so
people say well if i go to brazil can i
communicate what language they speak
well first of all many of you know this
but some may not know that brazil speaks
portuguese there's no brazilian language
there's portuguese
and portuguese
now if you want to go there and just
have enough of the language to say hello
and be friendly with people then all you
need to do is buy a phrase book
try to memorize three or four or five
expressions and that's all you'll be
able to do i had the experience i went
to vietnam
after
six seven days all i could ever say was
thank you please and goodbye that's
about it we just can't absorb this at
least my brain can't absorb it all that
quickly however if you want to really
get into the language which i heartily
recommend there's 200 million people in
brazil
uh a great place to visit i suppose i've
never been there there's portugal which
i know is a lovely place to visit
it's an important language in the world
and it's very similar to spanish so if
you already know spanish then portuguese
is easier for you in so far as the
vocabulary is concerned if you learn
portuguese you can then learn spanish
and french and italian other romance
languages
i would recommend that you get yourself
this little book
uh grammar books
are the smaller the better the simpler
the better
the more
examples of how the language is used
and if you get them without any drills
any exercise those are the best kinds of
books to get and it's a resource that
you go back to again and again and again
because you can't absorb all the grammar
rules and all the endings the first time
not even the second time and so you go
back and you go back and you go back and
every time you go back you pick up a
little more so i can give you a lot of
details about the portuguese language
and you won't remember a thing all right
let me just say in general terms
there are a number of things that
portuguese does differently from spanish
for example if you're familiar with
romance languages typically the you know
i have gone the auxiliary
verb to indicate the past tense is
avoir in french
in spanish but in portuguese they use
tener or the equivalent in portuguese so
that becomes the auxiliary verb you have
to be used to that there are some funny
things they do for example uh to think
it's not pensar passe it's
ashar
which is a find ashar is that's what
they use
and then they have very handy words like
ficar is to
uh
to be to get it's got a lot of different
meanings that you have to get used to
um in context
so there's lots of things to discover in
portuguese that make it a very
interesting language they have strange
not strange but interesting uses of the
infinitive that we don't find in other
languages they have a personal
infinitive and then they have this
future subjunctive that kind of looks
like the infinitive and so all of these
things are there they're explained in
great detail for example in this book
but
you should have
a few go-to
sites for any language you're learning
so if you were to google portuguese
grammar you could find tons of free
resources giving you chapter and verse
on portuguese grammar however you can't
learn the grammar from the get go you
can't learn the basics
therefore i would still recommend that
you expose yourself to the language so
that might be through a beginner book a
teach yourself or one of those you can
also go to
link our site where we have a lot of
beginner material for portuguese and
then that raises the question do we
learn the portuguese from portugal or do
we learn the portuguese from brazil
all right
my own experience and my opinion is in a
way
when you start out it doesn't really
matter
okay even though the pronunciation is
quite different and probably the
pronunciation in brazil is easier
because they pronounce all of the vowels
all of the syllables which the
portuguese from portugal don't they
sometimes kind of cut them that chew
them they don't kind of pronounce them
you know so there are some difficulties
there there are some issues in terms of
how the r is pronounced and you'll
discover in fact that the r is sometimes
a rolled r and sometimes a guttural r
and it varies all over the map depending
on where you are
but all of these things are difficult to
notice at first you shouldn't be trying
to notice too many things you just want
to get some words
and i'm always when i start out i'm
motivated to learn
to work my way through whatever content
i'm listening to and reading
and
in my own experience moving from spanish
to portuguese as long as i was trying to
use like i had living language before we
had link at
excuse me before we had portuguese at
link
um
i was using living language and and i
thought well it's just easy i'll just
convert my spanish to portuguese it's
not that easy because you have to change
your habits you have to change if you're
a spanish speaker whether a native
speaker or speaking spanish as a second
language as is my case
you have to change these habits and
we're kind of reluctant to let go
uh of the comfort of
spanish and so
to try and just pick up a few phrases
like oh they say this in portuguese
instead of this
uh is not going to do it
in my experience anyway so i wasted a
lot of time
trying to just pick up you know the few
ways in which it changes and then i went
to portugal and hoped that i'd be able
to speak and i wasn't able to speak at
all even though i spent weeks or months
doing a lot of listening to portuguese
phrases through the living language
course and stuff and i can still
remember where i was when i was jogging
and listening to all this stuff and in
the end it didn't work for me what
worked when was when at linc we had i
still remember ana paula from belo
horizonte in brazil she created a lot of
content about taking her kids to the zoo
and stuff like that interesting content
and we got cafe de brasil and a lot of
good content like that and then i found
some wonderful podcasts from portugal so
i was mixing them both mostly i was
interested in in tuning myself to
structurally
how they structure the language how they
express things what are the words and
you know it's different they use the the
two the singular form in portugal in
brazil they only use the voce which is
the third person for you
there's a lot of stuff like that you'll
eventually get used to it i think a
person
should do a lot of listening and reading
in both in the written form it doesn't
matter if you pick up a book
written by paulo cuello
it's not obvious necessarily i mean it
is in terms of any dialogue in there
whether it's
portugal or brazil go for both and then
at some point decide which accent you
want to focus on but
a lot of fun with portuguese i was
helped
with my spanish although in an initial
period it kind of held me back
um
but
uh
go for it
if you are already a speaker of a
romance language oh and add this other
one to your you know another
you know arrow in your quiver or if
you're starting from scratch and you
want to go to brazil or portugal do the
portuguese it'll open the door to other
romance languages so a language that's
well worth studying the main thing in in
you know tips on learning a language is
first of all to get people motivated get
them in the door
and then every person has to discover
the language on their own and just stay
with it until you get to
whatever you want to achieve and and i
think fluency and i'm going to be
stressing this more and more if you know
the common european framework b2 fluency
is achievable and that's the way we've
structured link and i think more and
more we're going to have the slogan all
the way to fluency so if you want to get
the fluency go for it portuguese for an
english speaker is a relatively easy
language to learn and for a speaker of
other romance languages extremely easy
but not a slam dunk not a slam dunk you
got to work at it thanks for listening
bye for now
you